âge demain à nancy inauguration du
nouveau haut de la pépinière un zoo
nouvelle formule à la dimension des
enfants et qui a la particularité de
laisser la place à des animaux familiers
que l'on pourra approcher plus
facilement après plusieurs années de
travaux le zoo est fin prêt pour
accueillir les petits visiteurs les
paons font déjà la fête et les bic est
né il ya quelques semaines à nîmes avec
drôlerie ce zoo nouveau type qui est
construit sur le modèle d'une petite
serbe
à pied ou en voiture à cheval la balade
devrait être agréable dans ce nouveau
les travaux qui ont débuté il y a deux
ans on était souvent interrompus
notamment par les inondations mais
aujourd'hui tout est prêt
les allées piétonnes sont achevées les
animaux presque tous là les nouveaux
surtout comme l'âne du poitou à qui l'on
devrait rapidement trouver une compagne
de sa race il y aussi un nouveau rocher
pour les singes encore en quarantaine
mais qui arriveront bientôt
en attendant les paons ont pris
possession des lieux des lieux qu'il y a
deux ans n'était plus du tout adaptée ni
au besoin les utilisateurs ni à ceux des
animaux sauvages souvent bien mal
installés alors 2 millions de francs ont
été débloqués par la ville de nancy pour
donner un visage plus humain à ce zoo ce
qu'on a voulu faire c'était surtout
lutter contre l'idée d'azo prison qui
existait auparavant et qui nous paraît
tout à fait tarim actuellement c'est
pour ça que nous sommes orientés vers un
sont destinés principalement aux enfants
qui sont les principaux utilisateurs de
ce parc avec des espèces naine des
espèces domestiques en voie de
disparition
nous n'avons gardé que les faux se
plaisait sur place et la preuve la
meilleure preuve en est qu'ils se
reproduisent régulièrement
nous avons également cherché à rendre
plus attractif le parc zoologique en
mettant pas mal d'oiseaux
ces espèces domestiques et des espèces
est plus exotique
quand le temps le permet quinze à vingt
mille personnes défilent chaque jour à
la pépinière et devant le zoo les paons
ne s'y trompent pas et préparent leur
numéro pour le grand public car la météo
a prévu du beau temps demain finie la
chair de poule et le froid de canard
l'inauguration du zoo sera l'occasion
pour tous les enfants d'être à la fête
comme c'est le zoo des enfants nous
avons voulu faire une fête pour les
enfants les invitons d'ailleurs très
très cordialement il y aura six sept
animateurs qui seront là qu'il est gris
marron en animaux qu'ils feront des jeux
de piste sur le thème du zoo sur le
thème des animaux vis des questionneurs
ses distributions gratuites de
friandises de tours de manège ces
commerçants se soient socialistes nous
on espère vraiment que ce sera ce jour
là qu'il prend dans la gueule des liens
visités leurs besoins et qui reviendront
d'ailleurs ultérieurement après
quant aux anciens pensionnaires il en
reste quelques-uns les ours qui semble
se plaire ici puisqu'il se reproduise
reste aussi les daims les pumas et puis
bien sûr jojo le gorille vedette qui à
34 ans attend sereinement
l'heure de la retraite